this is a production of cornell
university
um
so
um
i'm just gonna
dive right in you already know the title
of my talk um and i i think you know
unless you've been living under a rock
um
and uh you probably wouldn't be here
unless you had heard at least some about
some things about the impact
of or the contribution of livestock
production to
uh greenhouse gas emissions and and
climate change and so it's all over the
news and and
um i think it's it's
a good thing that it's it's out there in
the media where is receiving attention
but in some ways i do think it is um
a little bit
dramatic dramatized dramatized uh
because and i have these epa slides
similar to what jennifer had and
agriculture in the u.s is is contributes
about 10 percent of emissions when we're
talking about emissions though
obviously um percentages can be a middle
little misleading as as we know that us
is one of the larger contributors of
total emissions globally um and you've
already seen this slide so i'm not going
to go into it too much more um i'll say
that i do like to point out this this
jump in scales that um even though
if you
don't focus on the um on the on the jump
here um agricultural soil and enteric
fermentation appear to be similar but um
this this x-axis scale for the for the
soil management actually goes pretty far
out to the right
and then just to try and answer one of
jeff's questions right off the bat so
manure management
and manure emissions refer to any of the
emissions from
pretty much the time the cow
excretes manure until it's applied
to the soil
and that
includes both nitrous oxide and
greenhouse gas emission or is nitrous
oxide excuse me and
enter
nitrous oxide and methane emissions i'll
try not to confuse you with too much
with my word jumbles
um
and then in just a little little bit
more perspective on the role of these uh
different sources of emissions from
uh agriculture
um
in the historical
context we we see that there has been um
some
increases in both enteric and manure
emissions uh over the year um but
actually the the contribution from dairy
emissions has slightly decreased
um and it it's a little bit hard to to
see that in this figure but um that i
pulled that out from the text of this
report
um but you can see the
the red bars are enteric fermentation
and the
um enteric methane and the
purple bars up here are
um the manure management emissions
and i'll just comment that the the
change in the
um co2 equivalents for the different
years have to do with
um the warming potential as it's
distributed over
whether it's a hundred year cycle or a
20-year cycle
methane
i think on average stays in the
atmosphere about 12 years and so that's
why it has that much shorter cycle and
so in translating the the warming the
impact um
whether it's a 20-year
co2 equivalent or 100-year equivalent
there's
a lot of kind of
physics and and uh calculations involved
in um determining how
that actual radiative force that um
contributes to the warming of the the um
the atmosphere the climate uh
distributes over that different time
periods and so that's the the
um my layman's
attempt at uh trying to explain the
change in those warming potentials
but it's still a little bit obtuse for
me
so
um
i'm going to
move
into talking about dairy production in
particular however a lot of these things
concepts apply to other livestock
production systems uh except that um
other livestock production systems are
not quite as integrated as most dairy
production systems are especially in
this in the northeast and so
for example um poultry production uh
typically the feed production and the
manure management and the um
uh the animal raising facilities can be
quite separated both um
uh by in terms of owners and in terms of
spatial spatially separated separated
um whereas a dairy system although not
all feed is is often grown on the farm
but
especially in this northeast and midwest
area again
a lot of it is
and so
one of the things about agriculture in
general and dairy production systems in
particular is that they're very they're
really complex systems there's a lot of
movie pieces and as jennifer so nicely
um described there's a
variety of sources of emissions from the
enteric methane emissions that come from
the animal's digestive processes
to the manure management
emissions and then emissions from the
soil and feed production and that is in
addition to the
emissions um that come from the all the
fossil fuel use or electricity use
required to to power these systems
and so i i think one of the the
challenges that we have um in in fields
that that jennifer and pete and myself
are in is is how do we measure uh the
the footprint of these
really complex and
um lar spatially um disperse and open
systems
whereas if you're burning a gallon of
fossil fuel there's a very
straightforward equation you combust
that fuel you know exactly how much co2
you're emitting
getting a an estimate of the amount of
emissions produced from this uh complex
a dairy farm is a little bit more
challenging
and you know um it's this is probably
obvious but one of the reasons is that
we we can't see them so we we don't know
when we change a management practice if
how we're influencing that greenhouse
gas emissions it's not something that we
can go out there and capture and measure
directly um in most cases
um
and so
um i i often think it would be so nice
if i could just put a dome over
a dairy farm and then go in there and
and change some things and and
see how the the meters of of these
different emission sources change but
that's that's really not not feasible
um and so
what we do
in order to
get a handle on on these emissions
estimates is we break the farm apart
into little pieces uh and
then we
study and measure the the impacts of uh
different conditions
on the emissions or
other environmental footprint or other
response outcome
uh from those those little pieces and
then we assign equations um and
relationships to
uh the the management practices the the
conditions of those those pieces and sum
them uh and sum up the emissions
estimates from those from those pieces
um
and so there are a lot of different ways
to build a model uh models that estimate
greenhouse gas emissions from
agricultural systems
but even before selecting uh or
predicting the selecting the equations
that predict the emissions estimates
there are a lot of decisions that go in
to
how you will build that model that
determine its structure and then
relate to its function and application
and so here i just highlight a few of
those questions that need to be answered
by someone um
building a model and and that really
influences its its applications
um
and so just like in biology um
the form of an emissions model the
structure of it is really driven by its
function
um and i i just love this this picture
but i think it's it's quite clear that
this cow evolved specifically to act as
a couch for this dog
um so
just a little a little humor to mix
things up here
um
let's see oh lots of questions um
nutrient runoff and is is also very
important i'm focusing on greenhouse gas
emissions but i will touch on i will
highlight some um impacts of
runoff as well later
okay i'm gonna keep moving uh
but
right okay so
um
as i said the the structure of the model
is is important for
um
it's important to develop the structure
of the model that's suitable for the
application and i i think about model
applications as being in kind of three
different
categories with with some overlap
between so we have models that are used
for inventories what is the total
emissions um like uh jennifer
highlighted that that her and peter
worked on for new york state um and then
there are models that can be used for
decision support that say you know if
you change something what is the
expected impact how does that influence
your decision and how you manage your
your farm and then
of course models are used for research
to help us understand the underlying
biology probe the boundaries of our
understanding and define new
new research topics
okay so
how do these models really help us get
to
uh reduce greenhouse gas emissions
because that is really the the goal of
um what we're all working towards um
you know we
if we put numbers on our impact it
doesn't actually change the outcome so
just quantifying the emissions doesn't
make a difference
feed supplements that reduce enteric
methane that changes our footprint so
changing the management practices
actually is what
will change our footprint
um and so
uh a good
use of models is that we use these
models to actually influence our
decisions and so in combining the use of
inventory models as well as decision
support
uh to
and and um
having the the models guide our our
management practices
um and so the the reason that i think we
need both inventories and uh decision
support models is that um
is is connected to this this paraphrase
quote from lewis carroll which is that
if you don't know where you're going any
road will get you there um
and
if the the
role that i see as the inventories can
play is to help us keep track of our
progress and um set targets
uh set realistic targets and that's
that's really key right because if we
say if we set targets that aren't
achievable then um we're just going to
um
be spinning uh get defeated
um
and so
um when i think about trying to
transition uh the role that the the
dairy industry can play in um helping to
achieve um kind of what a maybe a good
global target of staying below 1.5
degrees celsius uh change in global
average temperatures or or two
um
depending on uh
the
what the global community agrees on um
i think that you know there's no way
that we can
transition to
being carbon neutral or negative
emissions in the dairy industry
overnight and so
um
laying out the path of what might be a
realistic
um
end goal and then intermediary targets
is really important and that's where i
think
inventory models
are
are critical because one we have to know
where we are in relation to this goal
and um
two
um
they can help benchmark help us
benchmark on our along the way
um and so
um one example of that is there was this
um
this
inventory estimate done by jude capper
and a few others um
that
uh let's see they published it in 2007
and so that compared our footprint in
2007 with 1944
um and they came up with this estimate
of an intensity of emissions for milk of
1.35 kilograms per of co2 equivalents
per kilogram of milk
um
and then they repeated that that um
inventory with some changes uh in 2017
and found that
you know based on their estimates that
we had actually reduced our intensity um
however production had increased so the
total impact
um would be
would be
increased um
okay
um
uh another example of some inventory
models that you may have have heard of
are these ones by uh
greg toma and
um
came out in 2012
2013 um and this newer um one by
um dr roths from the usda and his group
i'm going to dig more into this
newer inventory s
assessment a little bit later
but then there's also
a
this foods q group foods cube group out
in minnesota i want to highlight uh
quickly because they've done a really
great work on getting inventory
estimates for um the greenhouse gas
emissions of
uh feed production so that kind of
upstream impact of uh how what is the
impact of producing food for our
livestock producing feed for our
livestock
and um to
one of the com one of the questions um
is that they also include a
water use estimate both
um
for all of the feeds that they they
um include
and so just to review that so the kind
of the main objectives of inventory
models are to establish a baseline um
track progress and set goals and they're
often static so they they don't
represent the system over time and they
are
necessarily retrospective snapshot so
you can't get an estimate of the
inventory in new york state today or
even you know on january 1st you
couldn't get an estimate of of 2021
because you'd have to gather the data
in order to
support that estimate
um
and so then moving on into decision
support tools and how they differ and
why i think they are a critical
component
of this
of our efforts to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions is that without these
greenhouse gas emissions we we don't
actually oh sorry without these decision
support tools we don't actually know
how to get to our goals right we have an
initial inventory um it doesn't tell us
how how to get to where we need to go
um
and so that's
why we need decision support tools to to
map out the path and to in order to
achieve our desired admission reductions
and so there are
a lot of models out there
that act as decision support tools in
one way or another for livestock
production systems
a lot of them
these decision support systems decision
support tools that are in action today
are
at a smaller scale than the whole farm
and they might include some greenhouse
gas emissions estimates on them but i'd
say that the majority of
farms are i don't think i'm i'm
over generalizing that i i don't think
many people make decisions on how their
management practices influence
greenhouse gas emissions at this point
and so i believe we need to move in that
direction so some of these models that i
uh
and decision support tools that i have
here like amts helps to formulate
rations so how do you how do you
formulate the most efficient ration to
produce uh milk um we could transition
that into how do you how do you
formulate the most
uh the the ration that reduces enteric
methane the most
feed watch and tmr tracker help manage
the the farm-grown feeds
to know what your inventory is how you
can use that that resource most
efficiently other software help track
milk production and cow health to make
sure that your herd is is as efficient
as it can be and then of course there
are other software i don't have my john
deere on here
but that would be another one that helps
access in a similar way to some of these
animal and barn based
decision support tools but in the field
and so
there are also some um
existing whole farm models that
can in some ways act as decision support
tools and are moving in the direction of
of
serving that role for our farms even
though as i said it they're not actively
i think being used by by the majority of
our
of our production systems um so some of
these that um i'm gonna dig into a
little bit more include
comet farm cool farm tool
and
the manure dmdc
dndc stands for denitrification
uh oh shoot denitrification
i can't believe i'm forgetting this
right now but uh
uh it'll come to me um
shoot and then uh if ifsm is the
integrated farm systems model
uh sorry i will think of that name
anyway it's a started as a this manure
dndc started as a biogeochemical soil
model and then added some
manure management and animal
uh
process representations
to it
so
summarizing the the that comparison
between decision support tools and
inventory models
the objectives of decision support tools
are to predict future outcomes
provide feedback and informed decisions
and so decision support tools
are often
dynamic meaning that they
represent a system over time and because
of that feature it enables kind of
comparison of scenarios and also
comparison under different management
conditions
and they operate often at a smaller time
step
which is also
favors their application as decision
support tools um
and are a little more flexible in terms
of the
how
management
is represented within those those
systems
um one final
comparison between these two types of
models is that inventory models are uh
often
applied at large spatial scales for
example the country or new york state
for for jennifer and peter's case
whereas decision support tools are
smaller scale right so i mentioned some
of the field and cal models um and then
i think the the next really useful model
that i'd like to see widely
applied is are these farm models
um
and so most of the models that i've
mentioned so far are in this diagram and
it's
not at all a comprehensive list of all
of the available models but i just
wanted to place them in this venn
diagram that i shared before to let you
know um where i see them them falling
so really the only one that um is is
existing and out there able to be used
that i think kind of fits in this small
sliver in the middle of serving an
inventory purpose a decision support
purpose and and a research purpose is
the integrated farm systems model
although i i think
that comet farm and
manure and dndc are are kind of moving
in this direction
um
jennifer i guess uh maybe you can drop
in the chat should i do you want me to
uh answer some of these questions as i
go or should we save them for the end
i think you should save them for the end
i would like you to go through
okay okay thanks
um
so just a little bit more on some of
these existing decision support tools um
in case anybody wants to go poke around
and use them so comet farm is
it has it gets its name from carbon
management evaluation tool um it was
built out of a really um robust research
model called decent that's been in
development for
decades
that
simulates uh carbon cycling um at its
core
um and so it is um really
uh well placed to
um
for those interested in long-term
simulation of carbon cycling
and it represents multiple livestock
species so dairy beef and i believe
sheep as well
it's focused on field emissions and so
it has some limitations in terms of its
options for the different types of
animal management practices
but it is very user friendly and you're
able to import a lot of
data including the the soil data
specific to the
gis
map of your farm
another another
more recent model is the cool farm tool
this model comes out of europe it's a
proprietary model so there is a cost
associated
with it um
although i believe there is a version
that is free for farmers
um oh yeah it says it right here free
for farmers
but if you're a company
or
research organization it's not free
um
uh i think a nice a nice feature of this
model is it includes kind of a more
comprehensive set of environmental
impacts including
water use water quality impact and
biodiversity um it's relatively easy to
use i i put easy to use but um i don't
none of these none of these models are
something that you're gonna download on
your phone and
click a few buttons and and get your
footprint um
and then it's it because it was
developed in europe there's there are
definitely some limitations for how it
represents uh
green uh management and the systems that
we have in the u.s
one example for that is they have
their estimates for
soybean
uh feed production soybean meal feed
production include land use change
assuming that it's
that soybeans are coming from south
america which is where the majority of
soybeans fed in europe come from in the
u.s that's not the case and so that
impact of land use change uh on the
greenhouse gas emissions estimates for
producing soybean meal doesn't really um
isn't isn't
applicable to u.s
systems
um i do believe that they are working on
that
um
here's the name of that dndc model so
denitrification and decomposition
so
as i said it's a
really a detailed process model that
grew out of this biogeochemical soil
nutrient cycling model
it's
a daily model can be simulated for many
years
it's
representation of management practices
but for both crop and soils
are less flexible and less detail
than some of the other
models that
have just a wider variety of management
systems that can be
represented
and then there's the integrated farm
systems model so this model was
developed over many years um
by al roth and and several others at the
usda ars um
the agricultural research service
services
um
i think this is the really highlights of
this model is that it it does do a great
job of representing most of the commonly
used management practices in u.s dairy
and beef production systems
it also has these those comprehensive
environmental
impacts including water quality
estimates
greenhouse gas emissions energy use
although it does not have biodiversity
like cool farm tool does
there is uh grazing options
so you can have
some representation of grazings although
i think there could be some improvements
and the flexibility in terms of um when
and and how long uh the different animal
groups are grazing and also what types
of forage they're grazing but overall um
really
um
kind of comprehensive in terms of of the
the management options
the approach so this model is a little
bit different than on manure dndc
in that
it's not a continuous overtime but they
simulate 25
uh it's continuous for a year it
simulates 25 different weather years and
then i give this provides the average of
those weather years
and then they also
this this model has i think probably the
most detailed representation of farm
machinery and barn structures so
including
um
really good estimates for
um
the mechanical side of farming and what
types of emissions and embedded season
embedded emissions are um
uh associated with those um i will say
that this is designed as a research tool
and i i believe dr rotz would will still
tell you that today um although i i
believe it it is it can be used for um
inventories and decision support
if um if applied correctly
um so
check my time so just to give you a um
an example of how that integrated farm
systems model can be applied as an
inventory model um this paper
by dr rox and his colleagues is is a
great example it's a relative it's a
very new
very recent paper that just came out in
2021
and
so
this inventory was for the whole us
and so what they did is they used
the
agriculture usda
agriculture survey data to identify what
they believe were represented farms from
each of these regions
and
i i believe they came up with these
dairy regions based on kind of expert
opinions and number of cows
um yes i can put the rocks paper in the
chat
let's see
kristen i'll take care of that
oh
okay thanks thanks jennifer sorry i
should have uh should have shared that
earlier um
and so
um
when once they you know divided the
regions and then identified the
representative farms based on the survey
data
they then scaled the number of
represented scaled the representative
farms in each region
by based on the number of cows they
think those types of farms represented
and then
they
ran ifsm with those
based on on those management conditions
and
used 25-year 25 weather years and got an
average for
the the simulation outputs for those
25-year simulations and then they added
all of the farms up within region and
then across regions
um
and so some results that i want to share
just to highlight kind of the utility of
this this process is um the
they have you know a total dairy
footprint which is
again important to know kind of where
what our emissions are now um and
just um we shared the epa estimates
previously
so this footprint is 16 greater than the
epa emissions estimate but this emission
estimate it differs in that it does
include upstream um emissions
um
[Music]
footprints so that um sometimes
described as embedded emissions for
example in feed that's imported or in
fertilizer uh chemical fertilizer that's
that's
applied to the fields
and so if
um they
remove the upstream emissions of
the emissions associated with producing
anything that's purchased and brought
into the farm
then this estimate would actually be
three percent lower than the epa's
estimate
um
they shared the intensity estimates um
from uh cap dude cappers group earlier
uh and and they were about uh 1.6 for
2007 and then reduced to 1.34 2017. um
and so this paper is nice because it
does give you a range of intensity
estimates by region uh and um the rain
they range from like 0.7 to
1.5 and for the northeast region we're
kind of smack dab in the middle at
about uh one kilogram of co2 equivalents
per kilogram of fat and protein
corrected milk so that's what this fpcm
stands for
it is a way of standardizing
milk as a unit for
comparison so that it has the same
nutrient composition
and then another um
nice output from this model is or from
this
[Music]
the study using the model is that it it
gives you gives provides estimates of
the sources of emissions
and so
from the epa
estimates that we showed before
it is
uh similar to
um what uh
what those results were with enteric
methane emissions um being the
largest portion of the greenhouse gas
emissions from dairy production but with
manure management being the the next
highest
um
uh the next highest
emission source so
combining both manure methane and manure
nitrous oxide
um then
moving to the use of ifsm as a decision
support tool um there's uh this other um
uh pa recent very recent paper as well
um uh even though the first author is
different this is essentially the same
group of people um and um they took a
similar approach to that inventory
analysis um however
instead of trying to get an estimate of
the the whole nation's footprint as it
is right now um they um focused on
changes within the farm and how they
might um and how those would compare if
you uh change the
uh something if you changed a practice
um
uh on a on one farm
at under the same environmental
conditions
um
they so they compared the impact of bmps
which are best management practices
for three farm types uh in
new york state pennsylvania and
wisconsin
and then for the weather they used um
kind of a similar weather data set what
they use for the inventory to get what
they call the baseline estimates um both
with and without bmps and then they also
use climate projections to see
how the
these management practices might
influence or might be
more or less effective under expected
changes to the climate
by uh
the our our climate uh
projection models
um and so just to um give you
uh an overview there of the bmps the
best management practices that were used
for these different farms
this is not
all of them but i pulled out
the ones that they in their paper
described as being most influential
and so they had a variety of um feeding
practices so uh diet formulation um what
the cows are eating um
that they changed in with the objective
of reducing enteric methane and so those
included
reduced uh forage fraction so reducing
the amount of
high fiber forage feeds that are that
are fed to cows
and they increase the digestibility so
this ndfd stands for neutral detergent
fiber digestibility so the fiber that is
being fed
um is increased in
its digestibility and sorry this should
be efficiency and they also increase
feed efficiency um which is in line with
what the industry has been uh doing
recently this increase in feed
efficiency the trends in feed efficiency
and then they decrease dietary protein
and that
will not influence enteric methane so
much but it will influence
nitrous oxide emissions downstream
nitrous oxide emissions because if
there's less nitrogen in the manure
there will be less nitrous oxide
emissions from manure management and
from application to soil
in the new york farms so this new york
farm was a larger farm with 1500 cows
they had an anaerobic digest digester
as a bmp and then they also
assumed that they were using
no-till practices and injecting all
manure
and then finally all
all
simulated fields and crop production
included cover crops so there is never
exposed soil
um on
the for the pennsylvania farms
they
the representative farm that they chose
to compare from pennsylvania was a
smaller
grazing farm
and so
they also reduced the forage factor
extraction by increasing
concentrate supplement grain supplements
they also increase the digestibility of
the fiber that
those cows are eating and decrease
dietary protein
um
they because this farm is much smaller
it's not a suitable candidate for
anaerobic digestion
practice and so they
um the best management practices that
they simulated on on this farm was an
enclosed manure storage system with with
flair and they also had um
for manure application manual injection
instead of spreading on the surface and
um they limited that
that manure application to summer
periods um so
some results
uh from from that uh
this study uh
that the development and rats group
published is um
uh just real quick comparing kind of
between the baseline estimates and if
they um simulated farms that include uh
all of the best management practices
um and so you can see just by a quick a
quick glance you know at baseline uh the
total
emissions intensity is much higher and
then uh with with
all of the best management practices the
total emissions intensity is much lower
um the
biggest differences that you'll see is
from
the manure emissions
so here
this new york farm had quite a
significant manure methane emissions
output and um adding iron aerobic
digestion in particular reduced that
uh and then we have the orange enteric
methane bars here that were reduced from
those feed
different feed
efficiency and composition best
management practices
looking at the pennsylvania farm
so again just
generally baseline estimates much higher
if you apply all of these bmps together
much lower
the the key features that
led to reductions were
these barn methane emissions so this is
manure that's excreted
and then
kind of left on the barn floor in a
typical small farm like this might be
called uh called the embedded pack
manure system
and so by collecting that manure and
keeping it in an
enclosed manure storage facility and
flaring that methane
you can see that those black bars were
reduced quite a bit and then again that
enteric methane emission reduction um
uh happens as
well and so
um
just in the last uh couple minutes here
i want to say that that um
that i want to talk about um
why it's in
why
you know to get to an estimate like this
where we're
implementing multiple best management
practices and looking at the whole farm
output
is important
that why we need to use a
whole farm model instead of
estimating the impact on these
individual pieces separately and then
adding them up is because when we um
in a agricultural system like a dairy
farm there is a lot of feedback when you
move when you cycle from one part of the
system to another so i mentioned that
that dietary protein that we feed to our
animals will reduce the nitrogen content
of the manure that will reduce emissions
from the manure
management but also from the soil and
crops and that change in manure
composition will not only
impact the emissions and environmental
impacts from our field systems but it'll
also impact the composition of the
feeds that are produced and and feedback
into
the
quality and composition of feeds that
are are being fed to the animals and so
having a model that has
that connects all parts of the farm
systems that you're using and is able to
capture those feedback loops is really
important
and so that is is something that the
integrated farm system does fairly well
and something that we are doing in
within the ruminant farm systems model
which is the model that i um have been
working on with um a group of colleagues
for the past few years
and so this infographic
shows
uh kind of captures the the essence of
the model again taking um the
inputs that describe the farm management
and environment and weather and
simulating the nutrient cycling and then
being able to estimate key outcomes
including comprehensive environmental
impacts as well as economic and energy
production
outcomes
and so why is um this rufus project this
rufus model
needed and why is it different than the
some of the other models that i shared
with you
the reason is that
it um
it really emphasizes a different set of
model development practices that have
not been applied in agricultural systems
modeling
and so this emphasis on transparency and
accessibility to the model as well as
flexibility clarity and adaptability of
the code base is key to
the rufus project
we also are targeting
specifically that
space in the middle of that venn diagram
so that it can be applied as a research
tool an inventory model as well as a
decision support tool and so i think
having that specific objective really
sets us apart from
the other models that are out there
and so if we
achieve our goals then
rufus will be
interoperable with existing software
systems so some of those existing
decision support tools and data
management systems that i mentioned that
help
farmers manage their
fields and cows in certain ways
we hope to be able to import data from
them into the rubus model in order to
initialize the model and also
for rufus to be interoperable with some
of the the larger
regional and watershed scale models
all of those things will will combine to
have a well-documented model um and
also the the risk model
code and documentation will all be open
source making it more accessible we hope
the model itself will be more
sustainable and be able to be used and
adapted into the future
we really rely on
participatory modeling and so we have a
really active stakeholder advisory
council that was just formalized last
year although they've kind of been
functioning for a while
um
and we believe that this is important
both to keep us on track so that we as
researchers and scientists understand
the problem and what's needed
but also increases ownerships and we
hope will
help us transition these decision
support tools from things that we
believe have value but ones that are
actually used and actually
changing decisions on the farm as i
mentioned before
and so the visions of success for rufus
but really for for any decision support
model
be able to
calculate these baseline estimates of
what is our footprint now identify the
management practices and and help us
plan out the path to get to our goals um
change the practices
on the farms you know help to guide the
changes and practices so that we can
actually reduce the emissions and of
course uh have that that impact that
we're all working towards
um and so i say if we're going to
achieve our goals of building
agricultural production systems and
industries that don't contribute to
climate change
we need to
really strategically plan out
how we're going to get to our goals
and need to use uh continue to conduct
the inventories to the best of our our
our ability and um
uh increase adoption of these decision
support schools um so that we can
know how to get to what where we're
going and and um
how to get to where we're going and
actually actually
make the changes that will get us there
one last note that i'll put
in here is that data is really key to
all of these uh any of these steps and
models and so
without uh
well-managed accurate
accessible data uh none of this will
happen and so i think um
something that i that i didn't focus on
in this talk but it is critical to this
whole process is um
building tools that will that help um
farmers both collect and manage data so
that they um know what's happening on
the farm and then can share that those
data's with their consultants and
advisors um
in ways that that make it easy for
for the party for all parties
um so with that i i think i left just a
couple of minutes for questions uh it
looks like there's quite a few so
um
jennifer did you want to moderate them
or
should i
go through oh and of course thank you
all for your sessions and and please
feel free to email me if you have
follow-ups
um let's see are any of these systems
each of them
um oh jennifer you're writing an answer
okay um the majority of cows in the us
are
in confined systems or in confined
systems that have elements of grazing so
certain times
in our climate we cows cannot be grazing
all of the year um
but i don't have a good estimate of the
total number of grazing
systems in the us i think it might be
somewhere around 10 percent of farms but
i could be actually off on that
can you explain how agricultural
subsidies for dairy production
might affect how farm
how the farm manages greenhouse gas
emissions um
so jacob i i probably can't explain that
um except that there are not
national um subsidies for
um
management that reduces greenhouse gas
emissions now but there are some states
that do that california being the
example that maybe a lot of you have
heard of already so they have
financial support for implementation of
specific management practices
that
are
qualify as reducing greenhouse gas
emissions
um
the difference in methane is about time
scale yeah yes jeff
um
most of our agriculture greenhouse gas
emit greenhouse gases from
new york most of our
agriculture greenhouse gas emissions
from ruminant farming
most of our farmland is forage producing
or fallow grassland do you feel
there are regional specific research
questions on grassland utilization
grazing methods for carbon enteric
methane they could have meaningful
practical
and policy implications towards
greenhouse gas emissions absolutely um
so um if you
i believe jennifer posted that regional
inventory uh that
i i highlighted so that really
highlights the
regional differences and practices and
how that
those different practices and climate
conditions combined to produce different
greenhouse gas emissions intensities
so there are definitely
many groups that are looking into
grasslands and probing this
soil carbon sequestration question
rufus doesn't currently have a grazing
model although we can repre uh simulate
grass in a growing in a field and we're
working towards a pasture grazing a
simulation model
our our car the carbon
cycling model within rufus is based on
decent um that that
really
well-developed model of uh
soil carbon cycling and and so
we are hopeful that it will be able to
represent soil carbon sequestration and
highlight differences in
carbon sequestration under grazing
management practices but of course
the quest there are many excellent
research questions as you suggest
surrounding what
what grazing management practices
will actually have the soil carbon
sequestrations or just
a greenhouse gas emission reduction
benefits that we're working towards um
green
grazing cis graze like a dairy cow on
grass based system
typically will produce less milk than a
cow on a
corn silage and an alfalfa silage based
diet
and
so that often means that grazing um at
the cow level a a pasture-based cow will
will have
um
a higher enteric
methane emission intensity than
a cow on
a total mixed ration diet that's that's
fed in a confined system
however
that's why it's so important to take
into account the whole management system
because the a pasture-based system will
have much less upstream uh greenhouse
gas emissions from the the the feed
production and uh
fertilizer application
um
so
um
there are trade-offs there um i think in
terms of the carbon sequestration there
are still a lot of questions that need
to be answered in terms of stocking
density
grass types
total time on pasture
supplementary grain
for for the
pasture-based lactated cows so
i think that's a really long answer to
yes
you see hay on the farm
um yeah absolutely so the the
distinction between grass-based and um
grazing uh in you know the with the
addition that when they are
inside and and eating dried hay or
halage which would be um kind of a
fermented grass then
um then you also have to address that
manure management
component as i mentioned in the best
management practice from
changing from that bedded pack system to
a cover and flare system
thank you so much kristen we have
run out of time thank you for all your
questions people may follow up um
uh with us um
you have kristin's email
um
i want to segue into our next talk
um and say welcome to those that have
joined us um
just now and uh thank you for those that
attended for the first hour
this project is a collaboration with
peter woodbury and many others and it
has been supported by a usda national
institute of food and agriculture smith
lieber project
these recordings will be found on our
website
[Music]
blogs.cornell.edu
workinglands
within seven days of the event and you
should also get a follow-up email
so we've been designing this working
lens and greenhouse gas webinar series
for the third thursday of the month this
fall from 10 a.m to 12 p.m we will have
another series starting in the spring
but basically what we're trying to do is
have the first hour be a conceptual
overview of a greenhouse gas topic
like kristin talking about models for
livestock systems and thinking about the
greenhouse gas sources
and then we focus on the second
hour being some kind of an application
of that concept so a tool a current
policy or funding opportunity so for
example
we had kristin do models and we will now
have
dan ludwig talking about nrcs technical
service provider opportunity
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu